I love it. I love it. Just totally incapable of like reading
the room and being like, "Okay, that's the that's the common
enemy to our group." No, he's just like And him and Candace don't
get along either. They each other, too. And clearly he's still
throwing shots at Tucker. So, you can save that speech about
collective guilt. We've heard it four times now. We got that.
I love how much of a destructive force he is on the right, man.
He is a wrecking ball for the right, and I'm so here for it.
Okay. Kyle Kolinsky review on the Manga Civil War. If we go much
longer, I will probably switch over. We'll see. Both civil wars
that are going on. We have a Democratic civil war and we have
a Republican civil war. On the Democratic side, it's the best
kind of civil war because what we have is the people against
the elites. Um, and that's a good place to be because that means
all the voters are on the same page. Uh, you know, the people
are on the same page and it's just Democrat. >> Oh, the
music was uh moral >> leadership that is getting in the
way. So, we're we're staring down the barrel of the Democratic
Tea Party. It's already started with the election of Zoron Mdani,
but it's going to go further. I mean, we're going to get Grant
Platiner is probably going to win. Abdul El Say is probably going
to win. Um, you know, you have a lot of these Wait, does he is
Platner like back in polling well again? Hold on. No way.
That feels crazy to me. When was the last time they pulled this
character now? Katabazali is probably going to win. all of these
people who are running from the left flank and who are actually
fighting are probably going to win. So on our side, uh it is
the most glorious. He didn't just say something crazy, did he?
That like that seems a little weird that he said that that Platiner
is like winning. I thought Platiner was still like quite a bit
behind. Did that somehow rocket him up the polls? That's pretty
weird. Oh, hold on. Two weeks ago still leads in the polls despite
controversies.
That's crazy. of civil wars imaginable. On the right, it's a
little bit of a different story because uh you have the uh the
mainstream of the Republican party, right? The people with power,
um but also plenty of older voters in particular, older Republican
base voters in particular, and they're up against the uh Tucker/Ventees
wing, which is u you know, overtly white nationalist. And not
only do they hate the normal groups that Republicans hate, but
they also added Indians and to the mix. So, it is basically like,
no, I'd say the base, even the old people are already racist.
That's not really a different position.
Kyle's Kyle's already misunderstanding.
Fundamentally, the the core of the party is racist. And you are
you're getting away from that.
The um the Netanyahu loving wing versus the loving wing of the
Republican party. And that is an ugly and a messy that's a that's
a better way of saying a lot of stuff unfolded about this over
the weekend. We're going to walk through it. First, let's start
with Megan Kelly who's about to play a big role because she's
sort of um you know, stoking the flames of the fire here. She
did an interview with Tucker Carlson. Then she did an interview
with Ben Shapiro and it was like everybody was throwing haymakers
at each other and she was standing there playing basically Sally
Jesse Raphael for those of you out there those millennials out
there or Jerry Springer out there. She'd like, you know, ask
a question and they start shanking each other to death and she's
just, you know, like, "Hey, who me? I'm I'm not doing anything.
I don't know what you're talking about." But anyway, so here
was her reaction. Let's start with this. Oh, is this just going
to be I thought I thought Kyle was further into this. Megan Kelly
and
here this is what I wanted. I wanted Kyle's reaction to the trigonometry
interview. Okay, that's what I wanted. Not the not the Tucker
Carlson interview. We've we did that. We did that today. Okay.
>> And that's why you're so defensive right now. But we're
just getting started, bro. We're just getting started. So, here's
Ben Shapiro. And uh this is a rich argument from this guy. He's
with the trigonometry idiots. And this is I mean I think my head
actually exploded when I first heard this. >> I think this
idea that you're not allowed to have scorn for views that you
believe are damaging or deeply immoral, like truly bad. Like
for example, I don't even not even arguments, it's just statements
like you know Nick Fence is calling JD JD Vance's wife agument
or that J or like how are you supposed to respond to the argument
that that he has made for example that JD Vance is a fat gay
race trader who shouldn't be president of the United States because
he's in an intermarriage. Am I allowed to respond to score? I
feel like scoring is a >> Oh, hold on. Hold on.
Wait. One is talking [__] Okay. The other uh how
do I how do I describe
Back a race traitor. That's talking. That's not why he shouldn't
be leader of the Republican party. There would be if you asked
Fuentes why JD Vance shouldn't be leading the Republican party,
he wouldn't just say that, right? That's just talking [__]
Constantine trying not to laugh. >> Who shouldn't be president
of the United States because he's in an intermarriage. Am I allowed
to respond to SC? I feel like scorn is a pretty good response
to that and that that doesn't actually deserve a [laughter] debate
or a wholesome discussion and that in fact treating that as though
that is a rational idea is a disservice to rationality. But if
you treat all forms of that response as cancellation, that's
probably how you get to this math. >> But the same thing
applies to your genocide support. Oh my god, I can't I can't
deal with this.
Yes. Exactly. Which is the point Fentes has been making. If Kyle's
following Ben, you not just his genocide support because that's
not that's not like that sounds to Kyle I feel like to Kyle's
audience Kyle's audience would say, "Oh, so Ben supports Israel."
No, Ben will have personal conversations with Netanyahu. Ben
is personally friends with Netanyahu. Ben will go shake Netanyahu's
hand. Ben probably knows Netanyahu's kids.
It's not the same. Okay, it's not the same as like, oh, vaguely
supporting the state. That's not what he does. You have a long
track record of saying Nick Fuentes like on every topic but Indians.
I mean remember that old tweet where he said something like uh
Israelis like to build, Arabs like to live in sewage and bomb
crap # settlements rock. Now he since apologized for that. But
you said that, you believed it. You meant it, right? You currently
support a government that is massacring innocent people on a
daily basis. There was a story from recently where the IDF sniped
a a Gaza surgeon while he was in the hospital through the window.
I believe we played the video on this show and you're still defending
that government. What? What?
There's no way.
There's no [__] way. Is there It feels like Did that
really happen? They sniped a surgeon.
is sometimes I hear stories with the IDF and I'm just like, dude,
are these guys either they're being lied about
where they're like explicitly like trying to see what they could
get people to believe or disbelieve, right? Like they're they're
explicitly like, "Oh my god, this is so evil. They'll never they'll
never believe that we did this one. That surgeon's operating
on a little kid." Boom. You're still pretending like it's a defensive
war from Israel. Like you are just as grotesque in different
ways. And so to your point, like are there some things that are
worthy of scorn and mockery and derision?
You and I are both guilty of those things all the time. By the
way, like this is this is Ben Shapiro not realizing the monster
he created. He's out there. How many times has he been out there?
He has no problem using every divisive, bigoted argument you
can think of against Hispanic immigrants, for example, or black
people or women or gay. Oh, this is the unfortunate thing. Kyle,
you have to read with a little nuance here. Kyle doesn't understand.
Ben just pays people who do that. Okay. Ben is somebody who has
started a company so that he can take the couched positions and
look smart and have those people have people still look up to
him because he just take the couch positions but he pays all
the other people to have the bigoted positions. He doesn't want
that. He's just going to pay somebody to have those bigoted positions
so his company can benefit from them. He doesn't have to say
them.
People think that Ben is like really that concerned with staying
a big influence or Ben Shapiro being like a big creator respected
in politics. I don't think he is. I don't think he's expect I
don't think he really cares to maintain. I think he just says
like what his opinions are and then he's going to pay people
to say all the bigoted that he supports but he doesn't want tied
to him personally. That's it. People or trans people. There's
all hate hate hate hate hate hate hate hate. And then he goes
whoa. Why you hating Indians and hating? Cuz they took your ideology
to it logical. I just spit all over the place by the way. They
just took your ideology to its logical conclusion. That's it.
That's all that's all they did. They said that ditto with everything
he said except add Indians and edge and now you're going TO WE
WANTED TO CARVE out just wait hold on the Indian thing didn't
even matter. The Indian thing is just him trying to signal and
get like V on his side and maybe JD Vance.
That's that's all. It's just one group. That's all Ben really
cares about a woke zone for both and Indians but say yeah go
ahead. I think I just think it's very funny that we're spitting
these. This sounds like you. Yeah, I know.
Turns out when you have the read on everything, when you were
correct about everything, then smart people start just repeating
what you say. Even if they didn't see it, cuz either either they're
smart and they saw it or they're they're smart and they didn't
see it.
But I can I can tell you this on the fly as it's all coming down
the pipe. Panda Rider, week and a half ago, I laid these opinions
out. Kyle's just catching up. Ahead and hate black people. Go
ahead and hate women. go ahead and hate immigrants. Go ahead
and hate trans people and LGBTQ people. You created this, bro.
You created this and you're too dumb to realize that you did.
Like, I'm sorry. Clearly, you can't cherry pick hatred cuz the
people who go all the way will win out on the argument. And you
also can't cherry pick equality cuz the people who go all the
way will win out on the argument. And that's why we support equality.
>> We support equality. We support freedom. We support
treating everybody equally under the law with dignity and respect.
And on their side, it's literally a race to the bottom. And Ben
was going, "Wait, I was the gatekeeper on the right. Nobody was
supposed to go more hateful than me." Well, they did. As I said,
your options [laughter] are who do you want to is you're a right-winger.
Which team are you on? The people who support the old Holocaust
or the new Holocaust?
Those are your those are your two different camps on the right.
The pro people or the pro net yahoo people who's basically modern
day. All right. I'm still not done though. Here we go. So, here's
Megan Kelly. I I mean kind of like trying to play both sides
here and sit on the fence. This is not the central will not hold.
This is not possible. I think that what Candace Owens is doing
right now is evil. It is e Oh, >> this is a gay clip. This
is a gay clip. I don't want Kyle's reaction to this. Kyle's going
to say something stupid and I'm getting annoyed.
Okay, Kyle's going to check in on Fuentes himself.
You have to get before you get to anything remotely recommendable.
>> All right,
Ben Shapiro isn't dumb. He just doesn't care. He uses whatever
he can in the moment to push his agenda. People have to stop
thinking he has morals or some kind of grand point. Nobody thinks
that. Everybody thinks his he the only grand point is Israel.
Nobody thinks he has a lot of morals. Nobody thinks he has really
any morals. As we went through on this stream, Wavy, I don't
know if you were here, we went through his article from uh 2000,
no 2016. Yeah, 2016 where he laid out exactly like all of the
reasons why Trump was bad and would lead to like a race to the
bottom on racism on a whole bunch of things. Racism, he laid
out the the whole thing that would happen if they elected Trump.
Uh restrictionist trade policies.
What was it? I I tweeted about it just recently. Give me a second.
I can just go look up my tweet. Let me go find my reply. We'll
find the section.
In 2016, he wouldn't vote for Trump. And here were his reasons.
Because Trump would support I think there was one thing above
this. And then you get down to here. He would support trade restrictions
and targeting of political enemies and an anti-morality foreign
policy and government domination of religion and nastiness towards
women and tacid appeals to racism and unbounded personal power.
So, turns out the anti-morality foreign policy was maybe the
only thing out of the original like principal disagreements that
Ben had. It's like the only one.
It's the only one. This is Ben Shapiro's words, by the way, from
his article. That's those were his problems with Trump. Trump
did all of those things except basically the pro-Israel foreign
policy. Sorry, he he didn't do the anti-Israel foreign policy.
That's what that means. Anti-morality means anti-Israel foreign
policy.
Oh, maybe you could say government domination of religion, but
I would say he's put Christians first again, right? Like to some
extent he's tried to put I guess Judeo-Christians first. He is
clearly he's like trying to deport people who are against Israel
in a lot of ways. And I would say that's on the probably on the
basis of religion, too. A lot of people who are, you know, Muslim.
So, huh. I stand with the Constitution of the United States and
its embedded protection of my God-given rights through the governmental
checks and balances. Do you, Ben? Do you stand with that? Do
you stand with the checks and balances in your constitution,
Ben? Donald Trump does not. I stand with conservatism. Donald
Trump stands against it. Wow.
Literally, his whole article is like 100% correct and then he
just flips to the next election because he got a judge. Good
one. Good one.
We're still not done. So now Fuentes comes in from the top rope
and he Fuentes like he doesn't have the ability to like reel
it in when he sees somebody who's, you know, not a total enemy
of his, but also not a total ally. So Megan Kelly is trying to
fence it and instead of trying to attack Flies with Honey, he
goes straight to like ripping her into. [laughter] So huh. I
wonder if there's somebody else who does that who makes it like
a zero sum game like like essentially lets people know either
you're on my side or I kill you. I wonder if there's like a politician
that Nick like derives a lot of inspiration from who might take
that exact same approach and so he's applying that exact same
approach because he's seen Republicans bend over and take it
up the app without hesitation anytime somebody pressures them
in this way. You think you think that might be a part of his
calculus here? Oh, Nick just doesn't have the ability to hold
it back. Why would he?
Trump already showed that these people are all surviile. They'll
just bend the over. They don't care. He's just shooting his machine
gun in every direction. He's doing the say hello to my little
friend bit. And uh let's take a look at some of that. >> The
level of dishonesty, the level of lies and dishonesty. And by
the way, they're trying now to make me a scapegoat. Look at how
look at how all of them are treating me. All of them.
They're making me out now to be the scapegoat so no one can ever
criticize Israel. Too many people are criticizing Israel. So
now that Tucker had me on the show, they're going to dredge up
clips where I I say cool and everyone now is going to join in
and be complicit in it and throw me on the p and crucify me.
Bro, you threw yourself on the p, bro. What is this? Oh, you're
going to come after me just cuz I said I love
of course we are. What are you talking about? So that I will
die for being the one that will criticize Israel. Maybe literally.
Certainly. >> Okay, by the way, as one of the top Israel
critics in the country, let me just say, Nick, you're not helping.
Cuz then they get to look at you and they go, "All these people
who are criticizing Israel are basically gropers. They're all
right-wingers. They're all fascists. They're all in agreement
with Nick Fuentes." So when they criticize Israel, what they're
really trying to say is, "Oh,
Kyle's punching across the horseshoe." Kyle, Kyle, we don't punch
across the horseshoe. KYLE, [laughter] KYLE, STOP punching across
the horseshoe. I love him. And you have made that an argument
now that >> No. Um, these are fine arguments. These are
It's fine to say this stuff, especially when you're leftwing.
I'm just I'm laughing that like I'm I'm just I see parallels,
right? You want you want a goal accomplished. It's like there
is something to be said there. There's a lot of people who agree
with the strategy. Don't p don't punch people who are like trying
to pull in the same direction as you. Kyle is trying to pull
in the anti-Israel direction. Nick is as well. It's just funny
to make that same
>> Land with some people because you are anti-Israel, BUT
YOU DO also love him. Meanwhile, there's people like me out here
who are despis and I despise Israel and Netanyahu cuz he's basically
modern day. So, you're not helping. In fact, you're hurting quite
a bit. And I'm telling you, I'm not going on to the P willingly.
You
[laughter] How dare YOU SAY I SHOULD DISAVOW MY SUPPORT? Who
is this appeal to other than the people who actually And that's
the point. Nobody but the people who love him.
Wait, did he say did he say I love like I I support this still?
I think he probably would if he pushed him, which is part of
his problem. But he's doing the Trump thing where he's just saying
like, "Oh, they're just going to pull up some old quote and he's
never going to really disavow it or make a give an opinion on
it, right? That's that's what he's doing." Kyle's missing the
subtlety here. There is some subtlety.
I'm not taking back anything that I said. I'm not going to stop
focusing on Israel so Republicans can win elections. you. I'm
not going to stop talking about the And by the way, when Tucker
says this this speech about collective guilt, I have no idea
what he is talking about. I am a Christian. We are not talking
about genociding anybody. We are not talking about collective
guilt. We are possessed by the radical notion that the state
of Israel has something to do with I love that Tucker is like
largely viewed as on his side in this feud. It's like Candace
Tucker and him is like they've been grouped together by these
pro-Israel rightwingers and he still can't help himself but also
just starts swinging at the people who are viewed as in his tent.
[laughter] I love it. I love it. Just totally incapable of like
reading the room and being like, "Okay, that's the that's the
common enemy to our group."
Kyle
Kyle should get it cuz I thought Kyle sort of understood the
same thing. Kind of employed the same thing.
Nick just wants to be the guy who everybody thinks is going to
be honest with him, right? That's who Nick's trying to be right
now. He just doesn't understand that the right-wing like the
Republicans in your country, which is weird because he understands
it every other way. They're so racist. They all they'll like
agree to Nick to some extent, right?
You're the the Republicans couldn't win elections unless they
agreed with Nick to some extent. And so when he sees any hypocrisy
at all, he just gets to call it out now. He's the person living
most honestly by the MAGA principles, the America first principles.
And other people just don't want to admit it, but he is. He is
the He is the party distilled right now, which by the way is
horrifying. Okay. Yeah, that's horrifying that that's the way
the US is set up.
But I don't know. It was pretty obviously going in that direction
for a while now. True. Ben knew. I knew. Lots of people knew.
Lots of people could see the direction that party was going.
No, it was just like and HIM AND CANDACE DON'T GET ALONG EITHER.
[laughter] THEY EACH OTHER TOO AND CLEARLY still throwing shots
at Tucker. So, you can save that speech about collective guilt.
We've heard it four times now. We got >> I love how much
of a destructive force he is on the right, man. He is a wrecking
ball for the right. And I'm so here for it. >> Tucker said
he told >> I don't
I wish Kyle understood.
I wish Kyle understood
this sounds all I see. I just I have to start playing. Can I
start playing it? Can I start playing the music of Israel has
something to do with >> I love that Tucker is like largely
viewed as on his side in this feud. It's like Candace, Tucker,
and him is like they've been grouped together by these pro-Israel
rightwingers and he still can't help himself but also just starts
swinging at the people who are viewed as in his tent. [laughter]
I love it. I love it. Just totally incapable of like reading
the room and being like, "Okay, that's the that's the common
enemy to our group." No, he's just like And HIM AND KENIS DON'T
GET ALONG EITHER. THEY HATE EACH OTHER, TOO. AND CLEARLY he's
still throwing shots at Tucker. So, you can save that speech
about collective guilt. We've heard it four times now. We got
that. >> I love how much of a destructive force he is on
the right, man. He is a wrecking ball for the right, and I'm
so here for it. >> Tucker said he told the It's just like
I I hear what I hear what Kyle's saying. Trust me, I hear it.
I understand what he's trying to do. Okay. I understand he's
trying to say that this is like bad. Kyle's right. I think you
guys don't understand. This sounds all I hear is all of the people
on the left who were reing about how Donald Trump was destroying
the party for every election for the past like four sorry for
the past like 12 years now. 12 years. No, sorry. Sorry. Sorry.
The past like 10 years now. Every single time I have to hear
about Donald Trump is destroying the Republican party. He's destroyed
the Republican party. He's destroy He's destroying the Republican
party. And it's like now they're sitting here Nick Fentis is
he's destroying the Republican. Dude, you don't understand. You
don't understand. I'm telling you, you don't understand. Or here
here's the one way they're destroying the Republican party. If
the Democrats embrace Israel,
but I I feel like at this point,
I don't know if I don't know if you could put the genie back
in the bottle on that one either. The number one purveyor of
anti-semitism, that anti-semitism is wrong. Is that what you
saw in that interview? Was that what you got from >> In
other words, Nick Fuentes is saying, "No, he did kind of glaze
me." He did. That's what he's saying here. >> Why are we
still using that word? What does that word even mean? Sorry,
I'm possessed by the radical notion. You can call it identity
politics, whatever you want. By the radical notion that the state
of Israel cannot be divorced
from from identity,
from the excuse me, religious belief, which has defined their
community for millennia that they are the chosen people. The
reason why that makes absolutely no sense is because there are
so many Jews who are anti-Zionists.
There are so many Jews who will say it should be a what? I thought
I I've been hearing the numbers like 90% of people support a
state of Israel.
Isn't that
isn't that no
secular country? Hold on. What did What did internet ray say?
What did What did he just say?
I don't think Nick has Trump Riz. He's seen as some weird online
loser. That's how boomers will see him.
Okay.
I I don't know about that, man. I I don't know. I don't know,
dude. He's also pretty young, so it's it's He's not going away
anytime soon unless he
Oh, I was a gun, but you guys couldn't see it, right? He's not
going away anytime soon unless somebody takes him out. So,
uh yeah. I don't know.
I I just think you can't really fight the fact that he is massively
popular on like every platform.
And it I don't believe that it's astroturfed in like a a way
that most people would suggest. He is a genuinely compelling
speaker. It's the same it's the same thing everybody says. Every
single person who knew about Nick Fentes 3 years ago, two years
ago, right? Dude, he is so funny. I wish he wasn't so racist.
Dude, he is so funny. I wish he wasn't so racist. It turns out
the Republicans have been doing tremendous work in the field
of normalizing racism. And that has allowed this guy who when
everybody would see him, they go, "Oh man, he's really funny.
I wish he wasn't racist. He's really funny. I wish he was a racist."
Now they're going, "He's really funny." And nothing else.
secular democratic country in that region that gives equal rights
to and the problem is
for some reason all these people who want to do clip shows and
who want to make him look bad they go and grab the oldest clips
of him saying I love or something right
please for the love of god get clips only with this set in it
people don't understand propaganda at all every single time you
grab one of those sets one of those old sets one of those old
clips all people will do is go well yeah he was young well yeah
he was young yeah he's he's pretty Yeah, [__] it.
Everyone was a kid once
to everybody to say that it's it's all that are guilty. That's
that's the Netanyahu line. Netanyahu says we represent all. So
he's agreeing with the anti-Semitic Netanyahu line that all are
responsible for the genocide and the bloodshed and the ethnic
cleansing. I don't agree with that. I know way too many who say,
"Well, [__] them. You don't fuck." I don't think
Nick believes that all are responsible for this. He says it's
You can't disconnect the country from the ethnicity and religion,
which I think is true. It's not the same as saying they're all
responsible for that, right? There'd obviously be some people
who are principally against it. And by definition, you wouldn't
say they're personally responsible for that based on their DNA.
I don't think Nick would say that. I don't think literally anyone
would say that. It's just a stupid position to have. Represent
me, their whole group, not in my name or not in our name. Right.
So like, you're just wrong. You're just wrong. [laughter] >> Yeah.
Exactly. Evil Johnny Bravo. He's really funny, but he's really
racist. And it changed into he's really funny and he's really
racist to say it's an inherent in. It's just not true. They defend
their disproportionate repres representation and power by saying
they're smarter than us. >> Pensive goat. It doesn't matter
which way you change it. If that if that is being anti-semitic,
then it's moral to be anti-semitic, right?
If you if you say that, then anti-semitism can't be bad. It's
it's moral to be anti-semitic in the case where you can't separate
If you can separate them, then it's immoral to be or sorry, it's
immoral to be pro-Zionist. It's it's moral to be
Okay. The whole purpose of this rant is to be like, "Hey, you're
wrong for criticizing me and saying and making a big deal out
of the fact that I said I love him in the past." And in the midst
of that rant, he can't help but continue to rant against
It's incredible. Megan Kelly said he's Oh, man. Kyle really doesn't
get it. Oh, Kyle super doesn't get it. This is so weird. I feel
like Kyle's the populace guy. He should
Yeah. Holy [__] Watching back. We're of one mind.
He really doesn't get it. It's like very shocking to me that
he doesn't get this at all. I think this is like the
I think this is like the former SJW like wiring in his brain
getting crossed. Not that it's like good to be racist. I'm not
saying that. Um it's it's okay to be appalled by the things Nick
has said. Nick continues to say that's totally reasonable. I
don't have any problem with anybody pointing out that he's racist.
I wish more people did it in fact. But what he's not understanding
is this is like
this is like when Hutch says, "Well, Kyle's like really hard
on establishment Republicans or sorry, establishment Democrats."
And Kyle's like, "Yeah, but it's the truth. I tell the truth
about them." How the could you tell me not to tell the truth
about this? It's It's like my It's like my calling in life to
tell the truth about these people. That's That's Nick's built
an audience on people who feel the same way. except instead of
corporate Democrats, it's
so Kyle just doesn't get it. He doesn't understand that like
overlap. They do the same thing, right? People like Nick because
of his honesty on topics that would get him in trouble with like
the establishment in some way and they like Kyle for the same
reason. Uh I just think you have a lot more reason to argue Nick's
beliefs are morally repugnant versus Kyle's. He said awful, horrible
things.
Shut up. [laughter] Shut up. You know what's awful and horrible?
What is happening to our country?
[laughter] He said these awful and horrible things.
Grow up. How old are you? [laughter] The point is like literally
you're not allowed to criticize me because things are happening
in the country that are bad. [laughter] What is that? How is
that connected at all? There are words on a show on the internet
from a adolescent male live streamer and people are the the hand
ringing has got to stop. But wait, did you mean it or did you
not mean it? Cuz earlier you were saying, "I'm not apologizing
for that stuff." And now you're saying, "Oh, I was just an adolescent."
And also, no, it's not just words. It's an expression of what
your belief system is. And is it compatible with modern civilization?
When you say, "Was really cool." Incompatible. Quote, "I admire."
Incompatible. When you do Holocaust denial, incompatible. And
you go down the list here. I mean, why? Why? It sure seems like
there's a lot of people who Kyle likes. Hey, wasn't Ryan Grim
arguing the USSR had a right to exist last week?
Why the would this be wrong in that same vein? It sure seems
like there are a lot of people that you could admire in history
who were absolute monsters who genocided entire populations.
Sure seems like a lot of people love Julius Caesar. That dude
almost made it so France didn't exist.
Okay, he he almost killed off the entire genetic like ancestry
of France by himself. Okay, with his orders, his his armies.
He doesn't realize how far the overd window has shifted. It's
not It's not about like uh sorry. It's not about this being like
an acceptable belief. It is, hey, everybody believes this. I'm
just willing to say the one that makes me an okay guy. Like I'm
willing to say I'm willing to say the one that piss everybody
else off. I feel like he almost does the Stalin thing to make
this point. I don't know why people don't go after him for the
Stalin admiration. It's way more recent. He's gone way more into
depth on and doesn't have the tinge of trolling that the hip
comments have. Oh, he's not trolling about the hip comments.
The H comments are are passionate. Okay,
I I don't think he's trolling about the hippo comments.
There's two things happening here, right? There's, hey, yeah,
I've said some awful [__] but I'm not going to apologize
for it cuz I meant it at the time and I don't believe in it.
But the only reason people I'm not saying it right now. Find
me a clip. Find me a clip of me saying it like super recently.
I'm not saying it right now. It's really important that we focus
on the country right now.
If you see, listen, if you have like an example of me hate crimeing
a go ahead and hate me. But they're just words on the internet.
So unless you've got some problem outside of words on the internet,
shut up and get focused on the country is the direction he's
trying to go in right now. Nick's primary belief, primary motivation
is his own career, his own starlike like uh like his own rise,
his own, you know, ascending star. That's what I was going for.
His own ascending star. That's his number one priority. So that's
what he's he's trying to protect himself. It's not totally honest,
but he's painting it as honest. He's using populist rhetoric
to paint it as honest. I'm so I'm just still shocked Kyle doesn't
understand. Catholic Taliban rule in America. Quote, "We want
to go back to the Middle Ages." Quote, "Give the death penalty
to atheists and witches." Quote, "Democracy is wrong. Quote,
I hate the poor. I love the rich." Quote, "Dating women is gay.
Having sex with women is gay." Like that
Kyle is so gone.
Kyle.
Oh god.
Oh, I'm I'm losing all respect for Kyle. That's up. He doesn't
He doesn't He doesn't get it. He doesn't get it. The The having
sex with women is gay is like one of the funniest bits that's
such an obvious troll that like getting actually upset about
it makes you seem like Kyle's line right there. getting upset
about about that. Kyle getting upset about that is so funny cuz
it's just so to get mad about that. Hold on. >> What? People
people calling me gay cuz I've never had a girlfriend.
I think if anything if anything it makes me less gay. If anything
it makes me NOT GAY AS OPPOSED TO LESS GAY. NOT THAT THERE'S
ANY GAY, but it makes me not gay.
Like how do you not how could you're quoting this this bit? It's
like clearly a bit. It's like obviously a bit. >> WELL,
BECAUSE THINK ABOUT IT this way,
you know, a gay person, gay people do date girls all the time.
And when I said on Elijah Schaefer show and they said, "Have
you ever been in a romantic relationship? Have you ever had sex
with a girl?" And I said, "No."
If you name searched me on Twitter, as I always do, all these
gay people are coming OUT AND SAYING, "I'VE HAD MORE GIRLFRIENDS
THAN NICK. I'VE I'VE HAD more girls than Nick."
So, like I said last week, not only is not only is that thinking
flawed,
but actually it's the reverse that actually makes me really
more than anybody if if we're being if we're really being honest.
Never having a girlfriend, never having sex with a woman
really makes you more because honestly
dating women is gay. Having sex with women is gay
and having sex with men is gay. And you know, it's really it's
all gay. And if you want to know the truth, the only really straight
position is to be in a
That's it. So that's all there is. Being a migtau, a incel
is really the straightest position that you can have. Having
itself is gay. I think I think that uh it's really a gay act
to begin with. Think about it this way. What's gayer than being
like I need cuddles. I need kisses. Oh, I need I need the
It's all very It's all very soft. It's like it's
it's so it's such an obvious joke that Kyle's like totally biting
the bullet taking seriously. This is goofy. That's an expression
of what your belief system is. And people are allowed to disagree
with that. People are allowed to go this is pretty stupid. And
if your response is nothing BUT TO SAY, "SHUT UP. SHUT UP. YOU
HAVEN'T REALLY thought Hold on. I feel like I feel like there's
an there's absolutely a set of hypotheticals. There's like a
there's like a dialogue tree where you could convince Kyle that
supporting was okay. It's like at what point at what point in
America do you think if you found out that like people were like
doing something nefarious? They weren't controlling the country.
They were like siphoning wealth out of the country. It's like
you come up with some hypothetical where it's like at what point
would it be okay to violently like suppress them? Like you could
work him up with how he thinks Israel work with how he thinks
how he thinks Israel works and Apac works. I feel like you could
easily convince Kyle that was right. I'm not joking.
Right. Like at what point at what point, you know, at what at
what point in the Palestinian genocide does that I don't know.
I feel like there's a way. Just as long as you don't make it
about race, as long as you make it about like a group that is
not racial, that is like opt-in or something,
right? You you'd have to you'd have to figure it out. But there's
like a way you could convince him. I'm almost positive with his
his kind of like his base way of thinking.
I I just mean base level way of thinking. I I think you could
convince him. Thought through this well, have you? That's all
I've been hearing all week from Eric Mataxis. SHUT UP.
SHUT UP. [laughter] Shut your lying mouth from all of them. Shapiro,
this guy, the Christian Zionist, the pro-Israel crowd, the women,
Megan Kelly, he said awful, horrible, monstrous things.
You really don't have an imagination. You think that's the worst
thing happening in our country? If you followed the coverage
of the Tucker interview, you would think that this country is
utopic. And the only problem is that somewhere in the suburbs
of Chicago, a young man said some naughty
>> See how he downplays it? Oh, I said some naughty words.
>> Like, look around. 10 million illegal aliens in four
years. We're at war with
You have half the country is on welfare and hates Americans.
Hates whites.
He's literally like, "You're not allowed to criticize me because
things are happening. Why Why don't you talk about the things
that are happening instead of me?" Okay, [laughter] then we get
to So, Ben Shapiro runs to Jake.
I I feel like the
I feel like Kyle
does not
get it.
I feel like he doesn't get it. And it's uh kind of rough to watch.
cuz he usually gets it.
Um, not that you can't criticize the guy. I don't know. There's
a way of explaining it. I'll have to I'll have to do more research.
Tapper on CNN to basically be like, "These people are unacceptable
and bad and wrong and we need to push back on their and look
again, this is the problem is Ben, you were down for the anti-Hispanic
hate. You were down for the anti-black hate. You were down for
the anti-woman hate. You were down for the anti-trans hate. You're
down for the anti-gay hate. And now you're like, "OH, BUT NOT
ME." It rings hollow. You can't be a gatekeeper for what's moral
because you support genocide and everybody knows it. Everybody
knows it. Ben Shapiro laments that the left's attacks on white
Christian men created in them a feeling that they're in an identity
group of their own with group interests. The committed Zionist
complains that there are influencers who are fermenting and catering
to this group solidarity. Shapiro says Charlie Kirk forbade this
groper mentality. Influencers are fermenting and catering to
this group solidarity.
Benchmir laments that the left's attacks on white Christian men
created in them a feeling that they're an identity group of their
own with group interests. Bro, Matt Walsh Matt Walsh really is
a total loser, isn't he? Matt Walsh believes that, by the way,
that white men, white Christians are a group with their own interests.
Ben like clearly just ignores the fact that he pays somebody
who who uses his platform, his network to make these points from
TPUSA. But now the door has been breached as evidenced by students
criticizing Israel at TPUSA's Q&A events. Frankly, I think
that TPUSA could do a better job of working with some of the
personalities with whom it is currently working who are promoting
this stuff. He says that's them saying, "Stop working with like
Tucker Carlson." That's what he's saying here. But again, BEN,
HERE'S THE PROBLEM. YOU CAN'T SAY, "HEY, white Christians in
America, you're not allowed."
I actually have to get the exact version of this. What was the
Twitter account that he's looking at? Chris Manahan.
Chris Manahan. Hold on. I want to watch this full clip because
I don't know if Kyle's gonna watch it. Is Kyle watching
>> He like read it.
>> A feeling that they're in an identity group of their
own with group interests. The committ he's literally not going
to watch the clip. Watch the clip, Kyle.
watch the clip. >> Passing thing. I mean, this is a growing
thing. And there is a significant number of people in the Gen
Z, you know, demographic. Yeah, I noticed I put this in and I
noticed this this account, whatever account this is also clipping
um ADL that are they have they're they're talking about this.
They're amplifying a lot of this. It's just bad information that
a lot of people have and they were infuriated. I just looked
on social media. I'm sure you saw it. They were infuriated with
Eric Trump's answer and I kind of wanted to get your thoughts
on this and we'll dive into it >> Sure. Well, I mean I
think that we can start with what's driving this in the first
place. I think one of the things that that is driving this is
the fact that for a decade or more there was an attempt by the
left to basically target Christian white men. And there's no
question that this was true that that just in terms of policy
policies were designed in order to disadvantage Christian white
men whether it was going after the little sisters of the poor
or the attempt to meto anybody who who was you know masculine
in any way. The attempt to say the men could be women. The the
sort of DEI nature of all of American politics. the BLM movement,
which is directed at the idea that there's a white supremacist
superstructure. And in in saying that over and over and over,
what the left actually did is they started to create a feeling
in a lot of young white men that as targeted group, they actually
were an identity group of their own. And then now as an identity
group of their own, they must rise up and lay low anybody who
is not a member of that group. And there are a lot of influencers
and a lot of political commentators that we've talked about.
Is he really pretending
is he actually pretending that this
that he doesn't support Matt Walsh who who like actually hammers
this message all of the time
did he like you pay somebody who puts this message out in the
world Ben you pay him and I've seen your contract with Steven
Crowder seems like you can control a lot of the that he does
are fmenting this because it goes viral online the algorithms
particularly on X and on Tik Tok are very very fond of this I
think for a wide variety of reasons. Some decent and most not
decent. I think there are a lot of manipulations in the algorithm
there. But there are a lot of people who are perfectly willing
to cater to this and then to and then to sort of promote this
idea. And that's how you get to this place. I mean, the fact
that this was happening at a TPUSA event. And these sorts of
questions are the kinds of questions that that Charlie Kirk himself
was routinely receiving over and over. And it was clearly coming,
as Nick Fentes said, it was clearly coming from Nick Fentes's
side of the aisle. I do not think this is originally a general
outgrowth of normie traditional thought. A lot of the kinds of
questions that you're hearing here and the vice president was
asked last week whether Judaism was targeting Christians which
is an absurd contention just historically and contemporaneously.
Those questions are coming from a particular place and the humoring
of that particular place is something that Charlie actually did
not want to do. Charlie actually forbade the involvement of Nick
Fuentes and the Groper mentality and white supremacy from TPUSA.
Obviously that that door has been breached and I think that's
why you're seeing that at TPUSA and you know frankly you know
I I think that that TPUSA could do a better job of of working
with some of the personalities with whom it is currently working
who are promoting this sort of stuff. >> Does Matt Walsh
care that Ben Shapiro is like totally undermining him that Ben
Shapiro is totally making him look like a [__] I
leaning on Charlie I think doesn't work. Well, hold on. The thing
is Charlie the way the way Charlie suppressed Nick Fentes was
by canceling him, right? So, he could say, "Oh, I don't want
to cancel people, but that's literally the way that Charlie handled
this from the beginning." No, I'm just going to cancel you guys.
No, I'm not going to I'm not going to collaborate with you guys.
I'm not going to acknowledge you guys. I'm not going to deal
with you guys in any way. I'm just going to cancel you guys.
[__] you. [__] you. [__]
you. Strange. Okay, back to Kyle. Zionist complains that there
are influencers who are fermenting and catering to this group
solidarity. Shapiro says Charlie Kirk forbade this groper mentality
from TPUSA, but now the door has been breached as evidenced by
students criticizing Israel at TPUSA's Q&A events. Frankly,
I think that TPUSA could do a better job of working with some
of the personalities with whom it is currently working who are
promoting this stuff. He says that's them saying, "Stop working
with like Tucker Carlson." That's what he's saying here. But
again, BEN, HERE'S THE PROBLEM. You can't say, "Hey, white Christians
in America, you're not allowed to do identity politics." But
then turn around and say that Israel is Israel is an is a ethnostate.
It is a supremacist ethnostate.
You can't say I get IDENTITY POLITICS, BUT YOU don't get identity
politics. And guess what? The real the real correct position
is the position I have, which is none of you get to do it. Sorry.
None of you get to do it. It's unacceptable
because any sort and in any ethnostate by definition is anti-democratic.
It has to be. It has to be because what you're saying is uh we
are creating a two-tier system. We are making it so that some
people are full citizens with all their rights and others are
not. So that is it's by definition a faright
uh way to organize a country. Right? So I'm against it. You should
be against it. No ethnostates are acceptable. But what Ben Shapiro
wants to do is he wants to say we get one but you guys don't.
And that's why the argument is so hollow and they are failing
miserably. So Mark Leavvin uh jumps in and this is I mean you
think Fuentes is unhinged. [laughter] This is way is Japan not
a democracy. Um
Japan is a democracy. Sorry he's saying ethnostate. The issue
in Israel is you don't get a vote if you're a Palestinian, right?
You're on the land but you don't get a vote. I don't think you'd
argue Israel outside of the uh outside of the Palestinian like
contested areas.
No, you don't get a vote if you're Palestinian. You get a vote
if you're an Israeli Arab. Yes, but that's different.
I'm saying you don't get a vote if you live in the Palestinian
areas under the or under the PA. You don't get a vote in Israel.
Obviously, you don't. That's the
>> Way worse. Watch this. >> I got a very strange
text this morning from Tucker Carlson.
10:16 a.m. I'll read it to you for verbatim. Good morning, he
writes to me. The leadership at Turning Point has asked me to
debate you at their event in Scottsdale in December. I'm happy
to do it, and I hope you'll agree as well. Beyond the personal
insults, which I'll try to keep to a minimum, there are real
and important ideological differences between us, and I think
the country would benefit from an extended conversation about
them. So again, I hope you'll accept. Let me know. Thanks. The
guy is desperate. He's taking a hit on his podcast. His show
is way bigger than yours. like way way way not even close. Your
show is [__] nothing compared to his. So don't say
he's there's probably also just so you know internet right there's
probably a way bigger difference in most people's minds between
a group migrating to an area and then creating an ethnostate
versus like being there since spawn and creating an ethnostate.
You know what I mean? Like it's a little there's a different
vibe to like having an island that's always been your ethnic
group keeping it that way like intentionally by limiting immigration.
is a way different vibe than just like going somewhere being
roughly 50/50 at the founding of your country and then right
like it's just totally totally different. >> But he's not
he's actually not. >> He's fighting like hell for >> Yeah.
I think most people would argue this actually during slavery
that the US wasn't a democracy that if you have people in the
land who live without the like democratic rights that's probably
different. I think they would argue that also I think during
the time of slavery the US probably wasn't in a lot of ways right
then what was it I don't know you you'd have to you could have
an academic argument on this but it always becomes like super
it's certainly not in the spirit of democracy to have people
who are totally disenfranchised right like a significant portion
of the population like 20% of the population on a given piece
of land is disenfranchised
like I'd say there's some tolerance around the edges for some
reason to have a small portion of the population disenfranchised,
but once it gets past a certain point, you're probably like not
looking at a democracy anymore. >> His career is fighting
like hell for his reputation.
People are wakening to what scum he actually is.
And he thinks I'm going to platform him.
He thinks I'm going to help him kick up his podcast
What would Charlie say? What would Rush say? What would any rational
response? Here it is. I wrote him the following.
My family and I want nothing to do with you. what you've become.
You're vile libels against my faith, millions of Christians,
and in my view, what you seek to do to our country. There's nothing
to debate. You're a promoter. You're the modern-day David Duke.
I debate people with whom I disagree for a
>> Yeah. There's like an idea of democracy in Kyle's mind.
Like he's talking about like this American liberal, one person,
one vote, everybody deserves the right to vote that lives in
the country. Like that is a citizen of the country, right? Like
that's that's what he's talking about in terms of democracy.
That's his definition. It's very um myopic view. >> We're
a lot smarter than you, but for whom I have some respect. I'm
also disappointed in TPUSA that continues to platform you. It's
not about free speech. You can be heard by millions regardless.
Some unsolicited advice. Stop long enough to remember. >> I
got to I got to get to the end so Kyle can talk cuz I don't want
I can't listen to Mark Leavvin for any longer. I will kill myself.
>> Here's the point. This is the main takeaway here. Holy
[__] Mark Leavvin, Ben Shapiro, all these hardcore
Zionists who've been cheerleading a genocide for the past 2 years,
they are in no position to try to police the moral boundaries
of the right. And so now, uh, they're dealing with a rising tide
of, yes, legit
and and paleoconservatism. And they don't know how to deal with
IT OTHER THAN TO WE'RE GOING TO CANCEL YOU. WELL, OKAY, but then
understand that you are carving out special exceptions because
it's your identity group under attack here because you parttook
in all the hatred of black people and Hispanic people and women
and gays and LGBTQ people. You're fine with spewing hate all
day, but then as soon as Fuentes comes along and says, "I'll
do all that and I'll add Indians and people," then you go, "Oh,
no. That's unacceptable."
And so you like the fact that you won't even debate Tucker Carlson
is absurd. I Kyle keeps pretending the general Republican party
doesn't isn't racist to Indian people. Bro, everybody's racist
to Indian people. What are you talking about? And I do think
uh I do think he knows he can't defend on the substance what
Israel is doing, what Netanyahu is doing, the murdering of innocent
people day in and day out. And so he can't defend that. And so
that's why he's he's being a little [__] and he's
running away from it. And then he's bragging about running away
from it as if this isn't humiliating for him. Dude, this is super
humiliating for you. This is absolutely humiliating for you.
But again, let's just be clear again. There are no good sides
in this fight. The the two sides on the right are do you support
the old Holocaust or the new Holocaust? Do you support older
new? That's it. That's literally the whole breakdown. And I love
love seeing them rip each other to shreds and destroy themselves
from within. And this can only happen if Trump and MAGA are failing
colossally. And he is. And that's why we are where we are. Hey
y'all, do me a favor and like and subscribe. It helps out big
time in the algorithm. Wow. Thanks, Kyle. Thanks,
>> I'm not sure what I'm doing. Give me uh I need like
two minutes. So, I'm going to go I'm going to go find a video
to play for a second. I'll be right back and then uh I'll see
what I'm going to do. I might keep streaming just some some of
my own stuff. That's
>> We'll see what I want to catch up on here. But give
me give me a second.
What am I looking for?
>> We get a Can we get a clip? Can we get a
look for a palette cleanser? One second to throw up while I walk
away.
Can I find?
>> Should I? Nah. Nah. Hit hold on.